Honduras rompió relaciones con Taiwán la
decisión se conoció el sábado mediante
un comunicado de la cancillería
Honduras reconoce la existencia de una
sola china en el mundo y que el gobierno
de la República popular china es el
único gobierno legítimo que representa a
toda china Taiwán forma parte
inalienable del territorio chino
Taiwán respondió con el cierre de la
embajada y la salida de su embajador de
Tegucigalpa acusan a Honduras de querer
más dinero y avisaron de que china
incumple sus promesas
el Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
desea advertir a Beijing que sus
intentos de atraer a nuestros aliados
diplomáticos con falsas promesas para
exprimir nuestro espacio diplomático ha
dañado gravemente los sentimientos del
pueblo taiwanés y ha acelerado la
divergencia de las relaciones a través
del estrecho
el 14 de marzo la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro ya había comunicado que
cumpliría con su promesa electoral de
iniciar relaciones con china algo que
celebró Beijing
China acoge con satisfacción la
declaración positiva del gobierno de
Honduras sobre el desarrollo de las
relaciones con China y está dispuesto a
establecer y desarrollar relaciones
bilaterales con Honduras sobre la base
de la igualdad y el respeto
el último país en romper relaciones con
Taiwán fue Nicaragua A fines de 2021 con
la salida de Honduras ya Sólo quedan 13
países en el mundo con lazos
diplomáticos con Taiwán en 1949 tras la
victoria comunista en la guerra civil
los republicanos nacionalistas
instalaron su propio gobierno en la isla
de Taiwán muchas naciones opositoras al
comunismo establecieron relaciones con
Taiwán pero desde 1979 cuando Estados
Unidos inició relaciones con China la
mayoría de países miraron atraídos por
los intereses económicos que empezó a
ofrecer beiji